this is a production of cornell
university
thanks alan let's see if that stays up
there so it's it's fun i've been the
director of the national museum now for
23 months
and it's a pretty phenomenal place
you've probably all been there at one
form or another as a visitor we get
seven million visitors
a year which makes it the most visited
natural shoe museum in the world
and there's 127 million objects in the
collections
and 400 scientists
last year did research in 70 countries
and published 392 new species
so it's a pretty cool place
complicated place to get your hands
around
what's cool for me about it the reason i
came from denver to the museum was that
of those 7 million visitors 85 percent
of them are unique
visitors they're tourists which means
that every year there's a different 85
percent of 7 million which means over a
decade we'll see something like 60
million people
in the building
which is amazing which means that
equivalent of 20 percent of our nation
will walk into that building in a decade
so it makes it one of the most
visited
informal science places in the world if
not the most and that was what attracted
me there was this perception that
it's really important
that we communicate with people about
science in a very effective way
and we know that
kids
are scientists because they're curious
and
somehow they lose that curiosity some of
them do some of them don't
but whatever it is that persuades people
to keep being curious part of that is
this perception that science is a
valuable part of our culture so it's an
interesting place to be working because
the potential is huge the potential to
put those 127 million objects those 400
scientists and those seven million
visitors together and stir them up
is pretty cool as a potential and um
it's fun to come here to cornell i came
because i was invited by alejandro
gondolfo long-time collaborator she and
i have worked in patagonia for a long
time and amazing projects and related to
what i'm talking about today but i'm not
going to talk about the patagonian stuff
so make sure you get alejandro up here
to give a talk about the cool patagonian
projects
soon i also came to visit david skorton
who is uh your president and soon to be
our secretary of the smithsonian
and uh the handoff's gonna occur
sometime next spring he's gonna come to
the smithsonian on july 15th so it's uh
it's great to get back in cornell and
thanks for inviting me
i want to talk about
the origins of biomes and if you look at
this map of the tree canopy of the world
today you see that the world is by and
large
not that forested but the forests that
do exist occur in some pretty distinct
patterns you can see the tropical
rainforests you can see the bands of
boreal forest you can see the coastal
rain forests and you can see the
deciduous forest and then a whole lot of
white space
but as a paleontologist
who thinks about deep time the evolution
of plants but also the evolution of the
landscapes that host different kinds of
plants in particular trees i kind of
wonder how that pattern came to be
and with geologic time you have both the
evolution of different plant lineages
you also have the continents themselves
are in play the continents are moving at
some fairly good speeds actually
continents kind of trip along until at
certain points in earth history
continents can move several inches a
year
and over the millions of years of time
over which plant evolution is happening
the continents are moving around and
bang into each other
and we have this phenomenal
fossil record on the planet and i think
we're so lucky that our planet buries
its dead
right
it didn't have to be that way you could
imagine a scenario where planet didn't
bury its dead but because of the rock
cycle
as mountains erode and the debris from
mountains gets deposited in low-lying
areas the corpses of plants and animals
get buried and entombed and those layers
of rock
hold the record of the planet and so we
can ask sort of ask the question how did
that modern configuration of forests
actually come to be what was the pathway
to get there
and uh we've got additional information
that's kind of interesting and useful
this is uh dana royer's curve that shows
the last 600 million years
of
our best gas at carbon dioxide in the
atmosphere
and our best guess of when ice
was prevalent and one of the biggest
surprises for most people is that our
present planet a planet that's frigid on
the ends and warm in the middle
in fact was not always frigid at the
ends it's always been warm in the middle
but not frigid on the end so in fact the
periods of ice
there are two great big ice house
periods one around 300 million years ago
and one for the last 34 million years
but for the vast majority of the last
600 million years the planet
has not had
polar ice caps
so our present world is kind of this
weird anomaly relative to the history of
the planet and that makes you wonder
about how forests fared
in these different worlds in these
greenhouse worlds so greenhouse world
ice house world two great big mega
patterns the last
70 million years
shows
warming at about
a warm planet at the end of the
cretaceous into the paleo scene with a
spike in the early easting at 55 million
years a really warm period of 50. then a
gradual decline
about 34 million years ago the passage
between antarctica and and south america
opens up and the world cools
dramatically
it warms back up in the myosin and it
cools to the present time period and we
don't really get
ice in the northern polar areas until
about 5 million years ago
so in fact
those earlier ice periods when there was
no land in the arctic were actually
unipolar
in their ice coverage so we're living in
a bipolar
icy world for the first time
in earth history for the last five or
six million years
so the present distribution of forests
must
arc through that story somehow the fact
that ice comes and goes the continents
move around
and i um
hopefully that will pop back up there
um i
ran into this dramatically when i was um
an undergraduate and got lucky enough to
spend two summers in ellesmere island
about 1500 miles north of the arctic
circle as part of a
expedition to the arctic in search of
eocene fossils a woman named mary dawson
at the carnegie museum in pittsburgh had
posited that
the fossils that were found in the paris
basin in london and the and the bighorn
base in wyoming were similar enough
there must have been an arctic
connection
during the eocene it said you know there
was some way that these
would cross over the arctic and she went
to the arctic with the idea of
finding the earliest
pre-ice age fossils in the arctic and
she went to ellsmere island which is an
amazing place it's the size
of england and it's got about 200 people
in it
mainly inuits
hopefully this will keep going on that's
elvesmere in the middle there and her
first trip in 79 she found fossils and
what she found was amazing she found
fossil crocodile teeth
1500 miles north of the arctic circle
which
was surprising to her
and everybody else
i went with her the next couple years
and flying around in this area that's so
far north that there are no
um trees at all in fact the one species
of woody plant is the arctic willow
which is prostrate so it's not even
bushes in this this latitude and this is
an area where the permafrost goes down
for over a kilometer in depth
the mean annual temperature is minus 30
degrees
there's three months of sunlight in the
summer and three months of darkness in
the winter and the further north you go
the more that that barrier is but if you
fly around you see tremendously thick
coal seams
and the coal seams themselves are full
of those white rocks when in close
inspection are actually tree stumps
so here we are 2 000 miles north of the
nearest tree
and there are stone tree stumps
when you date these rocks they date
around 55 to 60 million years old so the
peak of that warming
instead of ice caps you have forests
which is a pretty amazing observation i
mean i think if you had to say two words
anybody talk about the impact of climate
change just say the words polar forests
or alaskan palms
and here's these forests they're lying
there and the coal seams are amazing we
found coal seams that are up to
up to 150 feet thick so some of the
thickest coal seams in the world
are actually polar forest coal seams
and
if you rummage around in the in the
footage of these coal seams you find
ample vegetation the conifers are not
the pinease that you find populated in
the boreal forests of today
they're in fact relatives of metasequoia
sequoia glyptostrobus
the cyprus
the warm conifers that are present
mainly in places like the gulf of mexico
and mexico and the yellow river in china
the mid-latitude warm conifers and these
are the dominant conifers
and you find a variety of other things
like these fragments and paleontologists
and paleobotanists are experts in
fragments we primarily deal in fragments
so you might not immediately see that as
the
besides the fact that it's totally out
of focus
you might not recognize that as a um the
center part of the lumbo
so we can tweak this i'm sort of missing
about half right it comes and goes okay
just thinking
um and here i notice as i'm walking
around the campus today there's tons of
beautiful sort of film trees on the
campus here and cersei the film is one
of the more common things that we see in
these polar forests so you have this
interesting world that kind of looks
like central china
except it's 2000 miles north of the
arctic circle
so those early trips in 84 and 85
drilled into my brain that the planet
is really different today
from what it was 50 million years ago i
mean dramatically different and here's a
a diorama that i built for the american
museum in new york of
the high arctic
55 million years ago and you have a
dense forest you have these big griffith
animals they're flying lemurs there's
crocodiles and turtles and snakes
there's lotuses
that's your arctic in the warm world
and one of the things we've learned
about the gradient is today if you think
about the temperature gradient from the
equator to the pole
minus 30 degrees
at the pole plus 30 degrees at the
equator today so this from the equator
to the pole today there's a 60 degree
centigrade gradient a mean angle
temperature
in the eocene
the equator was somewhat warmer we don't
know exactly how much but let's say 35
degrees c
and it looked like the polar regions had
a meaningless temperature around 10 or
15 degrees
so the gradient is much much smaller
another way to think about that is that
when climate changes it changes
much faster in the arctic regions in a
warming climate it'll it'll warm five to
six times faster than it does
at mid-latitudes
which is interesting because it means if
you want to see the future now
go to the arctic because it's happening
faster
there now so here's the arctic today
i mean if you go up there it's quite a
phenomenal place because it's an ice
scape and it's both the permafrost on
land and the floating sea ice at sea
and in 2005 there was an amazing paper
published by an american european
coalition that had gone out to the
middle of the arctic ocean
and they uh there's a submerged
ridge in the arctic ocean called the le
mans off ridge
and
you can see the this uh ridge going
across it's now about eight thousand
feet down in the bottom of the ocean
and they drilled the lamana's off ridge
and brought up seafloor samples
expecting to see
the
marine foram the marine plankton record
of the ancient arctic ocean and what
they found was really startling they
found
the spores of the floating aquatic
fernanzola
so you have an arctic ocean
that in fact not only wasn't producing
marine forams it was producing fresh
water fern spores
in great abundance and here's you've all
seen a zola that's what it looks like
and there were layers in these rocks
that are 47 to 50 million years old of
azola spores so you have this crazy
situation
of an arctic ocean that
must have had a freshwater lens on it
which makes some sense that you have a
closed basin a freshwater runoff into
the arctic ocean so a freshwater lens
lake floating on top of a deep saltwater
basin
and on top of that lake we're floating
aquatic ferns so
um here's a lake in amazonia i love
going to amazon it's a great bus man's
holiday if you ever want to go
experience delightful times but out in
central amazonia there are these
gigantic lakes that are so big you can
get on a small boat not see the edge of
the lakes
and the lakes are often totally covered
in zola
so here's an amazonian lake that is
actually the arctic ocean
of 50 million years ago which is you
know actually kind of a very compelling
thought to realize the planet has
changed that much
and most people you know have no idea of
the arctic
wasn't always polar and in fact polar
arctics well that is technically polar
let's just say frigid
phrygic arctics turn out to be
the exception not the rule and it's
pretty unclear exactly how the physics
of that works because we all know that
there's more sun at the equator and less
of the poles and the earth's tilt is
still there so how you keep the arctic
warm in a dark winter is an unresolved
mystery that some modeling progress on
but we don't understand that exactly and
it's not like this is just a chunk of
land that floated up there because we
have the same kinds of fossils all
around northern russia and in fact
antarctica as well so there's a very
good well-documented saga of warm polar
regions
in the warm world of the eocene and
paleocene
which sort of begged the question to me
when did tropical rainforests start
and the second part a little bit less
intuitive is where did they start
because they happen to be in equatorial
regions now we assume that they must
have started in the equatorial regions
but i think that might be flawed logic
now there's some argument for that and
just to sort of introduce you to my
basic tool which is the humble leaf
as a paleobotanist we find
leaves pretty frequently you could be a
paleobonus of your charcoalified flowers
like bill crepe and alejandra do here or
if can look at pollen grains and those
are all great ways to look at fossil
plants and fossil plants are great
because they
represent plants in many different forms
tree trunks pollen grains charcoalified
flowers or leaves but i'm a leaf guy
i like leaves and leaves are pretty
compelling things
and there's lots of them a single tree
can have like between 100 000 and a
million
leaves i mean i actually cut a tree down
once and counted the leaves just to
prove that
99 284
was the number of leaves on my tree her
50 foot tall red maple
and if you look at a leaf like this a
classic tropical rainforest leaf
it's got a couple of very distinctive
characteristics one a very smooth margin
and this elongate narrow tip also called
a drip tip
and this was noticed by a guy named
bailey who used to work here
back in the day
and published in 1915 this observation
that leaves are actually indicators of
climate that smooth margin leaves are
more common in warm climates
and that drip tips are indicative of
very wet places
in tropical rainforests
many of the leaves have these features
we did a survey in yashini in ecuador
and looked at 400 species and something
like 70 percent of the leaves had smooth
margins and elongated drip tips it's a
convergent forcing thing that show up in
tropical rainforest in very wet areas
not all
tropical rainforest leaves have drip
tips not all have smooth margins but the
percentage with smooth margins and drip
tips is much higher in wet tropical
rainforests
and here would be this is
actually
my bed spread in my hotel in
manaus and i've just laid out a sample
of leaves from an amazonian stroll in
the woods
and what you see is that by and large
the leaves are large they have smooth
margins a lot of them have drip tips
that's a classic tropical rainforest
modern tropical rainforest looking kind
of leaf assemblage
now this is a curve that shows you
without years but these are the stages
of the cretaceous period so buremian's
like 130 million years old cinematic is
about 95 million so it's from
130 to 95 and then from left to right is
paleo latitude with the equator in the
middle
north latitude to the right south to the
left and this shows the first occurrence
of angiosperm
pollen grains a very old slide there's
probably better slides showing this now
but what you see is that some of the
earliest angiosperms appear at low
latitudes
equatorial latitudes it's not a great
data set you can see there's a strong
bias towards mid mid latitude northern
hemisphere stuff which just reflects the
location of paleobotanists more than
anything else
but you see that by the cinemanian
at both poles north and south
angiosperms are present at the poles
so angiosperms appear darwin's
abominable mystery they appear
apparently right at the end of the
jurassic beginning of the cretaceous
apparently somewhere equatorially
and very rapidly cover the globe
so by a hundred million years you've got
angiosperms and pulled a pole in a world
with no ice you can do that
right so
you would think oh
there it is the first angiosperms are
equatorial
tropical rainforests are equatorial you
can read many textbooks that say well
tropical rainforests have been around
for hundreds of millions of years
they're they form the equators that's
why there's diversity because you have
they started there in a long time but if
you actually look at the fossils
these early
cretaceous fossils of angiosperms they
don't look like tropical rainforest
leaves
they're actually quite lobed and small
they don't have drip tips in fact
cretaceous leaves throughout the
cretaceous have a tendency to be a
variety of different shapes that might
even fit more with your mental image of
what a deciduous
forest would look like and that's not an
oak but it looks like an oak it's
probably more closely related to a
laurels but there's a lot of these
repeated shapes these load leaves are
pretty common in cretaceous floras
throughout the cretaceous and this in
fact this assemblage is from the last
two million years of the cretaceous
so you've got this world where
where you find them the leaves don't
really look like tropical rainforest
leaves and i spent a lot of time chasing
this problem around and i finally found
an equatorial flora in baharia oasis in
in egypt in 2000
and the leaves i found were small lobed
leaves
right on the equator 100 million years
ago
so it's an interesting question like
where you know if those are tropical
rainforests
when did they start and where do they
start starts to be a little bit more
compelling to me and if you look at a
reconstruction of the world 80 million
years ago which is in lake cretaceous
you're confronted by one kind of
dramatic fact which is
there wasn't that much land
at the equator 80 million years ago
so just even if you wanted to put
tropical rainforest at the equator
there's not really much place to put
them
you got to have land to put a forest on
it at the end of the day you can see
that the the great open ocean the tethy
sea separates north america and south
america separates africa and europe and
separates india and asia and separates
australia into malaya so there's a great
big east west
seaway in the cretaceous
that during the time of angiosperm
evolution and diversification
was clearly a barrier for the presence
of large tropical rainforests the big
exception being the northern tip of
south america
the northern part of africa and the
southern tip of india malaya so those
would be places you want to go look if
you want to answer that question
so again in mori
morley in 2000 published a book about a
very speculative book based on
pollinology primarily about the his
guess
of the origin of tropical rainforest and
he basically
proposed that
during the warm cretaceous if you warm
the planet up the equator gets
drier and then he sort of predicted two
sort of music wetter zones to the north
and the south
but a dry equatorial region
ziegler and his students in chicago
looking at the distribution of different
rock types have shown that the horse
latitudes
have been persistently dry through earth
history so you've got those deserts
north and south of the equator and the
question is
was there in fact any persistent wet
areas at the equatorial regions at all
now
the other way i backed into this
question was by studying the fossils of
the american west and in particular what
happened to plants
at the cretaceous tertiary boundary the
event where the asteroid strikes
smooshes the dinosaurs and my question
was what did it do to the ecosystems
and that involved collecting about 100
different quarry sites about 12 000
fossil leaves
in the rocks that had dinosaurs looking
at the pollen the leaves the dinosaurs
and what we saw there was a a diverse
lobed-leafed cretaceous flora gives way
to a very non-diverse
early paleocene flora
of basically wetland plants
and that was the picture we saw in north
dakota we took that work down to the
denver basin and when i moved to denver
in 1990 and started actually around
denver and denver turns out to be
an amazing place because it's in the
denver basin it's a it's a sedimentary
basin
that most of the rocks beneath downtown
denver are late cretaceous or
paleocene age so i moved to town the
first week i was there they were
building the denver international
airport and i got a call from a workman
out at the airport he said we found a
gigantic fossil fish
like that's awesome so i raced out to
the airport
and what they had found was a palm frond
which if you've never seen a palm or a
fish
might look like the tail of a fish
and we found huge palm fronds all over
the side of the airport when you fly
into dia you're flying into a paleocene
palm forest
and one of the most traumatic
experiences in my early character life
was watching a big track hole bury an 11
foot long pin 8 palm frond
on a big slab of rock that's underneath
like runway 2 right now
but i realized that come on i moved to a
museum that's literally built
on the kt boundary in fact the kt
boundary is in between the museum and
the airport
and downtown denver is in cretaceous
rocks and in 1992 we found a
tyrannosaurus rex in a backyard
it was the 11th known tyrannosaurus rex
at the time
we found several other dinosaurs in
neighborhoods in denver
and we started going out to construction
sites and one of the great things about
plants is they're more common than
animals
and so you might find one dinosaur but
for every dinosaur you'll find thousands
and thousands of leaves and we started
collecting fossils and we collected
about 200 sites in the denver area
and what was cool about denver was the
rocky mountains were coming up
exactly at the end of the cretaceous
period so the denver basin not only
recorded the cretaceous tertiary
boundary it also recorded the uplift of
the rocky mountains and the creation of
topography
so we had landscapes that range from
near montane out into flat swampy
landscapes we also had adaptive
conditions on a landscape as well as
change through time
and in 1994
i was sitting in my office and this guy
walked into my office and he had a
cardboard box
and he had been by the side of the road
25 miles south of town on interstate 25
in a place called castle rock colorado
and he walked in carrying four leaves
and the leaves were great big smooth
margin things with drip tips on them
and i had just gotten back from the
amazon like
where'd you get these things he said 25
miles south here on the side of the
interstate highway
so we went down there and dug into this
outcrop and it's the most nondescript
outcrop you can imagine i mean there it
is it's a slumped hill those blue tarps
are the holes we dug
and here's the guy with one of these
leaves
i always use some people for scale it's
quite handy
but here's a 24 inch long
leaf a big leaf it's like this long
and we dug into this site immediately
and
fossils were pouring out of the hill i
mean it was unbelievable everything you
found and what we actually found was
that there was a buried soil horizon and
for about eight inches above the soil
horizon there were just layers of leaves
so it was basically a forest floor that
was flooded
and these leaves are lying in there in
tremendous abundance
and of course we're along the side of
i-25 with 5 000 cars an hour going past
us
and we had a lot of a lot of media
showing up and we were pulling these
great big slabs out of the ground
that were curious because
people known about fossil leaves in
denver basin for a long time but
they had never found a site like this
before the site was unique
it had really big leaves it had a great
diversity of species a lot of the leaves
had smooth margins and drip tips on them
i'm like you know looks like a rain
forest smells like a rain forest
it just happens to be latitude 39.
at the time we didn't know the age of it
um and i was thinking well it must be
from the early years that's the really
warm time
what's also great was the fossils were
extraordinarily well preserved a lot of
them had cuticle and the leaves would
just simply peel off the rock it was
kind of tragic you split the leaf open
and a little the leaf would just peel
off and blow into traffic and get run
over
and
what was amazing about too was that
having spent
basically
already a decade collecting fossil
leaves in the dakotas in montana and
collecting literally thousands of leaves
and knowing quite well the cretaceous
and paleocene floors of the rocky
mountain regions this site contained
many things i'd never seen before
many things that are only known from
this site
and that seemed kind of odd big
beautiful complete things like this
great preservation
and then just
50 with drip tips
so it seemed that
if you were to use those characteristics
to recognize
a
wet warm place this place would qualify
and here's a just a garden variety leaf
from the amazon and the garden variety
leaf from the rain forest castle rock
as we did more work and did the dating
in the site we actually were able to
show the site was 64 million years old
so not not only easy but in fact early
paleocene
just two million years after the
cretaceous tertiary boundary
and what was kind of cool about the site
was it was an in-situ site that is to
say we actually found standing in place
plants so you can see here where the
hammer is there's a trunk going
vertically and those are roots radiating
out on the soil surface
we're able to actually uncover the
forest floor itself
and
see the forest floor which means that we
were able to map then
the occurrence of fossils on a landscape
next to a highway
and here's uh as we dug this we dig in
with backhoes and then we take the
fossils out and we were digging here we
realized that we were following these
big trails of carbon and we realized it
would actually
expose the base of quite a large tree
the rope is a ring of carbon those other
ropes are other linear bands of carbon
what you're looking at here is
basically a carbonized base of a
gigantic tree trunk
and one of the things that we always
think about as
when we're casual sloppy thinkers is
where are the petrified trees but
petrofaction is a process that happens
sometimes
in areas around volcanoes but most trees
don't get petrified most trees
rot away
for a walk in the forest
the corpses of the dead trees are
reduced by termites to carbon dioxide
and the tree goes away so the fate of
most trees is not to become a petrified
tree
it's to become carbon dioxide again
so when you walk through forests
you think about the forest there's not
much that tells you about the history of
the forest because the trees are are
basically being returned to the
atmosphere
and so it's not a surprise not to find
petrified forests but then you realize
you can actually find the traces of
trees other ways
and start to get a sense of where the
threes were so you start to think okay
here's what this place must have looked
like big trees small trees
and
abundant palms
again same guy for scale so you have to
adjust your mental thinking
and not only abundant palms but a bunch
of different kinds of palms right so
there's there's a host of different
palms
today there's some a couple thousand
species of palms palms tend to be plants
that don't like places where the ground
is frozen you probably couldn't do too
well the palms here in ithaca i would
imagine
but here in the denver basin where ample
palms pinate palms costa palmate palms
palmate palms
abundant
and then we found this beautiful frond
meter-long frond of a cycad
and while we were digging we actually
realized that we'd found a whole cycad
plan this beautiful thing
there were 25 fronds laid out
and a trunk in place
and was kind of fun because when you
work for a museum you can just call up
the evening news we came they came down
at five o'clock we opened this thing
this outcrop
live at five on the evening news
always striving to communicate science
whatever possible way and here's a
reconstruction of this
a still unnamed genus of palms it's
similar to diawan
but it's not dia1 and we actually found
next to the trunk
in place seedlings
of the palm
in place
so
we published we did an analysis using
leaf margin and got a mean annual
temperature on 22 degrees c
a meaning of precipitation of over two
meters of rain
and
um over a hundred different species
in the initial analysis and as we kept
digging this site because
there was more road work and each time
they did more road work they found more
fossil sites so we kept going back
we kept finding more and more species
here and it was a staggeringly diverse
fossil site i mean fossil leaf sites
typically have 5 to 25 species
these sites are producing 60 to 70
species
for a single hole in the ground which
would be equivalent to a single grab
sample of leaf litter in the forest
floor think about it that way and it's
actually difficult to get 60 species in
a leaf letter sample because when you're
even in the most diverse tropical
rainforest in amazonia
you can only pack so many trees into a
certain amount of space
and the leaf litter is only capturing
the leaf litter from the nearby trees so
it's even if in yasuni or or manu it's
pretty rare to get more than 45 or 50
species per leaf sample graph we're
getting as many as 60 here and here's
just a rarefaction curve from one quarry
there of just dicot diversity 73 species
from 500 specimens
so hyper diverse
64 million year old
tropical rainforest not in the tropics
and here's a here's just a view of
the fossils laid out the footlong ruler
over there for scale
and this site really kind of rained my
bill said what in the world is going on
here
what does this say about tropical
rainforest origins and i went into the
literature and looked for the evidence
in the tropics of early tropical
rainforest and it's pretty sparse
it was after this site that the site of
sarahone in colombia was discovered
which is late paleocene about six
million years younger than this as
perhaps the best known equatorial
tropical rainforest site
so we did a landscape transect here we
had this long hill we were able to cut
into the soil a long length of it and we
did that in many places
the lowest layers of the rain forest is
you can see the tree trunks in place
and we then took the
common taxa and we census them along the
hill so you imagine if you're walking
through a tropical rainforest as you
walk through the forest the leaf litter
beneath your feet changes its
composition as you walk under different
trees
because the trees are heterogeneous in
distribution in the forest so as you're
walking through the forest you'll your
leaf litter will literally change its
composition and our hypothesis was that
we'd see the same thing here
and so what you're seeing here is
the distribution of this leaf cr23
large there lower or else but if you go
across the ladder you can see that these
different species appear sometimes
broadly distributed sometimes local
sometimes spiked
all the way across
the forest so there really was like this
heterogeneous distribution of species
across the landscape at the same exact
stratigraphic level which seems to
suggest we have the same heterogeneity
that you get in a tropical rainforest
now a lot of these things down below are
things we've never seen before
and i started scouring the literature
for those species in the paleo botanical
literature
and coming up pretty dry we we did a
painting of this reconstruction of this
landscape
what it looked like and you can see that
uh the cycad
everything here is based on actual
fossils with the exception of the
buttresses the buttresses are an
artistic conceit that obviously makes
you think tropical rainforest
so i admit that up front
we did not find any buttressed trees
that little critter there that's a
selena daunting teeniodont
which you may not have ever heard before
it's an extinct lineage of mammals that
appears in the early paleocene because
extinct in the lady is seen known for
probably less than 15 skulls
and while we were doing this excavation
these guys were driving down the road
nearby
it's a true story they stopped to take a
leak on the side of the road
while they were taking the leak they
spotted the thing they thought was a
coyote skull
they brought it to the museum
and in fact it was a paleocene cylinder
daunting teeniodon so we actually have
one of the denisons of this forest and
it turns out in paleontology that peeing
is the best way to find good fossil
sites
because most people don't look at the
ground until you're actually like oh my
god there's a fossil there
so don't ever feel bad about it it's all
good
so now the context of this site is that
in the late cretaceous there was a
seaway that bisected north america and
north america was actually
western north america was effectively a
peninsula of asia
sitting down and we were starting to
call this peninsula laramidia
and
there was a wide sea that at times was
about a thousand miles wide 600 feet
deep that separated larimidia from
appalachia or
effectively flooded most of kansas
nebraska
and you can see the colorado's net space
if you look at this diagram you can see
in dark red the uplifted blocks of the
rocky mountain range and in the denver
basin we can actually date quite
precisely the uplift for the rocky
mountains we see
in the stratographic layers adjacent to
the mountains we see the first
appearance of gravels being shut off the
mountains so we know that the rocky
mountains first breached the surface
about 68 million years
ago
and the site at castle rock is right up
against the mountain range we know the
mountain range was there at 64 million
years ago and in fact we even find
lahar deposits which are lahars are
these volcanic mud flows that came off
volcanoes the around denver there were
volcanoes they're gone because volcanoes
are ephemeral but the debris from
volcanoes gets buried we find lahars
that are composed of chunks of volcanic
rock and petrified palm trunks
so there's vault there's palm
studded volcanoes in denver
sliding off the mountain range into this
tropical rainforest landscape
i hope you get to see these things
should come in
um
so here's the location of the castle
rock rainforest
up at the foot of these mountains and
then
one sometimes these things are so
obvious you don't notice it but when you
go to denver you live in denver they
have a thing called the monsoon
which is not the monsoon of the
himalayas but they talk about the denver
monsoons and what the monsoons are is
that in the
spring in the fall
when there's cold weather coming down
from the north and moist which are
coming off the gulf of mexico you get
heavy rainfall
on the eastern side of the rocky
mountains those are the monsoons
and so we did some modeling and it turns
out in a warmer world
we have a closer wetter water source
you can predict much higher rainfall on
the eastern flanks of these mountains so
that this is an orographic effect we're
seeing that's why we didn't see these
things before is the previous fossil
sites weren't close enough to the
mountains
to actually get
enough rainfall to make the rainforest
so it's like oh yeah rain forests are
truly localized
in fact to
places like volcanoes which give you
localized high elevation and orographic
increased rainfall
so that was the sort of the model for
this thing
and in morley's book he prints this
really interesting diagram
with not a lot of evidence for it
frankly
he kind of deduced that
in the paleocene there might be as many
as three bands of tropical rainforest
one equatorial
one mid-latitude north one mid-latitude
south
and you know that was an interesting
hypothesis and it's curious that the
castle rock site is pretty much where
that northern band is located
so
in my mind that starts to be a
compelling story
and then the question is how what's the
evidence for that equatorial
paleocene rainforest
we have the one site in cerrone in
colombia
but boy that big band in central africa
unexplored that big band in amazonia
unexplored
so these are hypotheses right we don't
really know
when the equatorial rainforest kicks in
primarily because lack of of exploration
and fossils which is the argument for
paleontology in general as the good
stuff is all out there still
so
further work on the study as we started
digging into the affinities plants most
of our plants seem to have asian
affinities not south american affinities
which makes sense because
they were a peninsula of asia
in a warm world you can get stuff across
the very land bridge and down
obviously south america is a long ways
away
so if there were these three bands you'd
have a northern band
with asian affinities a southern band
with australasian affinities
and who knows about the equatorial stuff
the bit of evidence we have from the
pollen record suggests that south
america has some input from africa
as well in the in the eastern now just
to close this up i um
my day job now is has imperiled my
extensive field work which is annoying
in the extreme
but i um i still continue to do uh
various kinds of public communication of
science i'm doing a three-hour tv show
for nova about the making of north
america it's a geology of the continent
and they're flying me all over the place
and i'm working with ray troll who's an
alaskan artist about a book about the
west coast so those two things i slip
out the door occasionally and disappear
into the wilds and i've been spending a
lot of time between seattle
and fairbanks
up the coast so one of the questions i
have is like this place today
is home of the great
temperate rain forest the pacific
northwest so from northern california
all the way up to effectively the
latitude of home or alaska you have
temperate
conifer dominated rain forests and it
occurred to me to ask the question when
do those things show up when do you get
your first
western red cedars and your dog furs and
your sitka spruces one of those kicking
gear when is this forest this is the
forest of my childhood when does this
forest come into being
and so i've
now found three sites
that are pretty interesting in this
context
the checkernut the kutsunahu and the
chickaloon
great names
none of these are
well studied yet they've all been known
for a long time as most fossil sites
have been but most people look like
fossil sites we're collecting the
fossils and not thinking about
the site or the location and of course
this is a landscape which is full of
exotic trains these are chunks of many
continents that hit the cars the north
americans slide upwards to the slot so
there's some northward translation of
these things
but it depends where you're on the
faults and and we now
have looked at these three sites which
seem to be in a docked position when
they were deposited so they weren't
carrying fossils and docking after they
had fossils they were docked and the
fossils were buried in those locations
and in chucking it in washington state
which is amazing is it looks like castle
rock there's palms there's big leaves
with drip tips there's huge leaves
there's cycads
and
in kutsnahoo which is uh it took me a
long time through this there was a paper
there's a paper in 1911 of a usgs
geologist who went um to kupernoff
island which is east of sitka
in southeast alaska and he publishes
just a few general slices there's
hamilton bay
and near cooper now island but in there
there was an illustration of a cycad
and one of the species that i have from
castle rock in colorado so after much
negotiation to figure out where little
hamilton bay was in finding the boat to
get to little hamilton bay
um i went to hamilton bay in 2012
and it's a pretty cool place it's a
pretty nondescript bit of coastal alaska
and we cruise around the bay and there
was almost no outcrop we're like where
was he digging the fossils and the tide
went out there's about 15 feet of tide
there there's a tidal now you can see
slabby stones right at low tide
so we went ashore and started pulling up
these big slabs of stone
and
there was
and one of the left is actually a castle
rock species it's one i've only seen
that castle rock
and as we dug further
we get into these really curious cycads
was this really that triangular apex is
actually
not an accident we found several of that
preserved on them
but just two months ago i took the nova
crew up there
and at low tide we popped out a gigantic
palm frond
at low tide and as we as we did this
other tide came up and washed over the
top of that thing and we hauled away
this thing we got this still size it's a
seven foot wide palm frond at latitude
57.
so i say to you alaskan palm
right polar forest alaskan palm
and where are the sitka spruce and it's
like this is this is a different world
again that we've ever thought about a
different forest
probably in this case not an orographic
forest but a coastal forest or a coastal
horographic kind of situation a wet warm
landscape and it turns out um
we'll be going back to this spot for
sure but
the chickaloon
which i thought was more of a temperate
flora and this is what you find in
museum collections the chickaletta again
the meta sequoias the comptonias and
things like that it turns out they're
palms in chickaloon as well
so there is this pacific northwest coast
floor that's only known from a few
places and no one's really kind of put
the whole story together yet but i think
there's it's very curious what do you
want to call this forest but it's not
the forest of today
and it tells me that there's an argument
for a lot more fieldwork and
the warm world of the past is a pretty
compelling way to talk about climate
change i find because fossils are data
man if you show a fossil of a palm in
alaska
and we're redoing the dinosaur hall at
the smithsonian now i arrived there and
immediately closed at that answer hall
for its first ever renovation
and it will take us several years to do
it but when we reopen there'll be this
palm frond from alaska
in the exhibit and it'll just say
alaskan palm
thank you very much
so
plays a significant role in many ways
because north america is moving in fact
elsewhere island is a lower latitude now
than it was when it was had those
fossils on it so what you have to do
with any fossil site is do your best to
reposition it
where it was when the fossils are
deposited secondly the continents come
together
and close off when south america hits
north america changes circulation and
rainfall locally or creates mountains
and
in addition these exotic terrains come
in and smash into the west side of
america may see the western part of
north america it's created by microcon
that's slapping into the side of our
camera and sliding north
so there is a floor for instance in
washington state called the wizard flora
is about 115 million years old that
looks like
the floor that made that was the
positive of the ladder of mexico
and the flora was then buried fossilized
and that chunk of rock stood out in the
position of washington state that's the
baja bc concept they call that um
malcolm mckenzie's they call that the um
viking funeral ship another vikings when
one of the key biking guys would pass
away they like barry won the shipments
of the ship out the city there's a dead
guy floating so it's a dead home
floating
and um there's that kind of so there's
lots of ways that you have to understand
your your continental literature
techniques to interpret these things but
once you deconvolve that
the story comes into focus
the idea of a tropical plant community
reacting to like
you know three four five months of
darkness at a time is super weird
um
are there any thoughts about especially
if it's migrating you know from an area
below the electric circle through the
arctic circle through those extreme
variations in like daylight hours are
there any like
thoughts as to how that's shaping or
affecting these plants that are migrated
through that area so
yeah this is a really important question
and i think what i showed you like that
palms is high enough is 61. but 61 is
still south of the arctic circle the
floors from elsmere appear to be all
deciduous
so you know the situation seems to be a
perfectly reasonable response than the
white
in fact you think of deciduousness as a
response to cold winters but it could
just as well be a response to the light
right if you don't there's no light will
have a leaf
so and there if you think about it
there's even an argument that
deciduousness
started in no light conditions because
in a warm world we're getting a cold
weather
so you might actually have an exception
from polar darkness during deciduousness
that's pre-adapted for life in the cold
world which evolves later
so the the northern extent of tropics or
for that matter the southern extent of
tropics remains an interesting question
because we're finding tantalizing clues
that both across virginia and across
scandinavia and across antarctica that
some things that are pretty tropical
managed to get across
so we do have these time periods and
there's one called the paleozoic thermal
maximum 56 million years ago where in an
already warm world in an already
ice-free world
there was an abrupt
60 degree centigrade spike
so and that doesn't last very long last
100 000 years but a hundred thousand
years is plenty of time for a monkey to
walk from manchuria to wyoming
and we think that in those moments when
you have they're very the hyper thermals
are on these things we have
hypothermials you might be able to
squirt
tropical adapted packs across polar land
bridges
and that's kind of the interesting thing
for me and we see examples of this
both in the north and the south where
things that are pretty thermophilus have
representatives on both sides of land
bridges how'd they get there is a pretty
good question
but fully tropical stuff and then
you know once you get away from you have
to be careful about terminology because
tropics definitely means between the
camp tropic of capricorn and cancer i've
completely abused the use of that
terminology in this stock you're using
traffic to describe i have a plant
conversation a climate parameter
and so equatorial is probably a better
word but i i'm really fascinated by this
stuff and i think that
it's the reason we haven't been finding
these things everywhere is that you need
photographic conditions
to have the heavy rainfall to give you
the evidence and the temperature is
there from other proxies it's just a
matter of targeting our search image to
find more examples of this stuff
question is about finding forest fires
in the fossil organ we certainly find
charcoal all the time
so a charcoal has got to be a forest
fire it's actually quite abundant both
macro charcoal and micro charcoal of
course these charcoal flowers these guys
are evidence of forest fires
um and one of the things that's getting
interesting is that we predict forest
fires in the q2 boundary
we don't find the charcoal at the tp
boundary it's very interesting we find
charcoal throughout the cretaceous and
the palestine but actually at the qt
battery itself
we don't see charcoal that's predicted
by some of the scenarios that we have
so i'd say there's definitely good
evidence for forest fires
say except your degrees latitude what
would the winter temperatures i mean
you're saying the model is not very good
yet but when both winter temperatures
get down
well this is the thing right i mean
we've got um
i mean you can do the experiment take a
crocodile and turtle and snake
and see where they go we don't seem to
have palms
that far north and palms don't seem to
like frozen ground
um so conceivably things that could
hibernate or be deciduous i mean it may
not they might be
pulling winners and then um in 2012 they
went up to the colorado river in alaska
and on the global river there are bone
beds of dinosaurs that are 70 million
years old and they're
i was i've heard about this for years i
just wanted to check it out i found two
things that i went there that were kind
of surprisingly one was the bone beds
are primarily babies
they're um they're small they're duct
talented but most of them are small
animals about this big these are not
migrating animals animals that were born
locally
um and died in some sort of probably a
big storm surge about the beaufort sea
because they're they're literally
we i dug one third of a cubic meter of
this bone bed that got 260 bones
the little tiny baby dinosaur bones and
the bone bed went for miles
but also their volcanic ash deposits
there volcanic ashes are really great um
thing for fossils because if you think
about volcanoes they erupt
and the ash rains out of the sky that's
basically like
raining out of rock
and they bury landscapes so you get
pompeii like
situations in uh pompeii is a great
example maybe the best fossil site in
the world i would argue is a site called
ashfall in nebraska it's in the middle
of nowhere in ambassador it's worth
going to would say it's about 11 million
year old ash fall from an eruption that
happened in idaho and it buried a herd
of rhinos
in place
and um it's amazing that their baby
rhino is next to the mothers there's
birds it's everything is exactly as it
happened 11 million years ago
and about 1990 scott william the
smithsonian found a asphalt dairy
cretaceous meadow where the ash buried
an herbaceous ridiculous landscape with
all the plants and growth position
as you can actually see for the first
time what herbaceous vegetation of the
quotations looked like and when i was up
in the colvell river
there were these ash beds and i just
picked one up the bottom of it and it
was just covered in ferns
so there's this world up there in the
cretaceous that's
you know i think the other point about
the hierarchical warm situation is that
because we talked there was a lot of
discussion about the place and thermal
maximum it looks like the warmth there
was a long life and the high wall was
sporadic it was it was always forested
and so
in my mind that biome the arctic
forest biome
of the eoc is a really cool place to
study because of those issues of winter
darkness it's got to get cold right but
people have modeled methane clouds
they've modeled warm currents they've
modeled a variety of ways to keep it
from getting frigid
i think it's a challenge
if i get cold but it can't be frigid
okay
this has been a production of cornell
university on the web at cornell.edu